horizon zero dawn is packed with
collectible whether it's all your logs
documents Austrian artifacts well in
fact there are three items directly
linked to debt stranding the highly
anticipated Hideo Kojima game currently
in development here's where to find all
three Easter eggs and the mysterious box
you receive for locating them all the
items can be found in story missions so
I'll hide spoilers first up get your
back sighs not to the grave heart and
loop around to the left as clear as day
the bright purple collectible is staring
you in the face on closer inspection it
looks like the necklace won by Norman
Reedus from the original set stranding
trailer the description reads the
mysterious item is valuable only to the
most curious merchants thick tarnished
metal ingots threaded with a plain wire
and look even the item icon is in the
shape of Kojima Studios mascot Easter
Egg number two is found behind horizon
zero dawn Coliseum you'll probably find
it during the story mission but if
you've missed it don't worry just simply
up sail back down and walk around to the
right
this one looks remarkably similar to the
handcuffs in the desk rounding preview
these are in fact the stranded shackles
one final Easter Egg to locate which is
close to where you began the game again
don't worry if this sounds a little
ambiguous you'll lost probably find this
during a starter mission go down the
first flight of stairs you come to and
turn back on yourself to find the
stranded figure which is a child's toy
baby which looks damn scary
you should remember it from the death
stranded trailers as it washed up
against the guillermo del toro the
description even says the figure smells
faintly of decay so after all this hard
work we should get something fantastical
right well next we need to find the
correct vendor to sell these items to he
can be found in Meridian and looks like
he's wearing his undies underwear on his
head for your troubles he'll give you a
mysterious box and what could be inside
well amongst other things the only not
where the item is a pair of warm socks
some people believe the stocks have a
but personally I believe the whole thing
is just a nod to death stranding as
Kojima is using the horizon zero dawn
engine known as a decimal engine to
create his next video game just in case
they do have a youth
I'll be keeping those socks in my
inventory if you've enjoyed this video
please drop us a like and think about
subscribing I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade see you next time